こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
皆さん
ご存知でしょうか？
まぁ結構有名だと思うんですけど
まぁ俗に言うお化け屋敷ですね
めちゃくちゃ怖いと言われているお化け屋敷なんですけど
まぁ僕も結構オバケ
ってかそう言うお化け屋敷苦手なんですけど
もしこのめっちゃくちゃ怖い戦慄迷宮というお化け屋敷に
史上最強にビビリの男を入れたら
どうなるのかやってみたいと思います
で、なんかこの戦慄迷宮今聞いたんですけど
7月にリニューアルされているらしくて
また怖くなっているらしいです
俺の知る中での最もビビリな男を連れて来ましょう
けんすけ：俺は違うっすよ
はじめ：いやだ、違うんじゃないよ
けんすけ：俺は違う
はじめ：違う、違うからやるんだよけんすけ
けんすけ：違うんすよ
はじめ：えーけんすけです
はじめ：彼はホラー映画見てても1人だけ
はじめ：部屋の隅で聞きたくないぐらい、めっちゃ怖いものが嫌いで
はじめ：せんりちゅちゅ
はじめ：戦慄迷宮入るなんて多分もってのほかだと思うんですよ
はじめ：嫌ですか？
けんすけ：嫌です、1回行ったんすよ
はじめ：1回行ったの？
けんすけ：1回もう本当に連れにいやいや連れて行かれて入ったんすよ
けんすけ：1個目か2個目のところでもう僕だけ出ていきました
はじめ：で、7月にリニューアルしてもっと怖くなってんだって
(けんすけ：無理無理無理無理)
はじめ：というわけでかつて1回リタイヤしている男がいるんすよ　開始5分で
はじめ：で、この男をまぁビビってるのもわかってるし、嫌がってるのもわかってるんですけど
はじめ：何とかして
はじめ：俺がなん、ん？？
はじめ：この企画は俺がこのビビリの彼を
はじめ：なんとかして、なんとか気合いでゴールまで絶対導くんで
はじめ：ちょっと彼の精神状態を見てみましょう
(けんすけ：無理無理無理)
はじめ：頑張ろうぜ
(けんすけ：無理無理)
はじめ：というわけで早速、この男と戦慄迷宮最後まで行ってみようと思います
はじめ：行くぞー
(けんすけ：………)
はじめ：靴忘れてる
はじめ：じゃ行って来まーす
(いってらっしゃーい)
はじめ：行って来まーす
はじめ：では行って来ます
けんすけ：事故これ？事故？
けんすけ：うわああああああああああ
はじめ：あああああああああああ
はじめ：はい、というわけでもうすぐ始まります
はじめ：どうですか？
けんすけ：も、もう終わりました
けんすけ：もう終わりました
はじめ：いや、まだですまだです
はじめ：今オープニングを見終わって、こっから中に入るという流れでございます
はじめ：戦慄迷宮で撮影できるってすごいことだせ
はじめ：撮影禁止を撮ってるんだよけんすけ、やるっきゃねー
けんすけ：え、えーちょっと待ってー
はじめ：うーーわぁーーー
はじめ：やばいやばいやばい
けんすけ：絶対ここからくるじゃん、横
はじめ：いや、来るねこれ
はじめ：うわっ、けんすけ大丈夫だ落ち着け
はじめ：笑顔笑顔、ファミリーファミリー
はじめ：けんすけ、ウィーアーウィーアーファミリー
けんすけ：ファミリーファミリー
はじめ：ウィーアーファミリー、ウィーアー
はじめ：けんすけちょっ本当に怖い、勘弁して
はじめ：けんすけ、けんすけしゃべ、喋れたら楽になるからけんすけ
けんすけ：ん？
はじめ：喋ったらね
けんすけ：うん
はじめ：喋ったらね急に出て来てもね大丈夫だからけんすけ
けんすけ：あーなるほどね
はじめ：うわっ怖い、怖すぎ
けんすけ：なるほどね
はじめ：あっあっあっ、待ってやばいっ
けんすけ：あ、喋ってる時は大丈夫
けんすけ：でもわかんない
はじめ：待って、待って待って
けんすけ：あーなるほどね、そういうことね
はじめ：こっち来てる×５
はじめ：こっ、うわあああああああああ
けんすけ：あああああああああああああ
けんすけ：わかんない
はじめ：待てーー落ち着けーーー
はじめ：静かに！けんすけ待てーーー
けんすけ：わかんないよー
けんすけ：マジで無理
はじめ：待てーまだ大丈夫
はじめ：もっとだ
けんすけ：無理だ　あああああああ
はじめ：待って、赤い(？)ーーーーーーー
はじめ：待って
けんすけ：うわあああああああ
はじめ：けんすけ！
けんすけ：なんであそこ行けないよ
はじめ：違う！違うんだよ
けんすけ：あそこは行けない
けんすけ：無理だよ　無理だよ
はじめ：気持ちで前に進まなきゃダメなんだよ
はじめ：大丈夫
けんすけ：行くとこじゃなあああああああああ
けんすけ：行くとこじゃないもん
はじめ・けんすけ：あああああああああああ
はじめ：うわっこの道やばっ！！
はじめ：この道やばっ！！！
けんすけ：無理だよ
はじめ：髪の毛！！けんすけ、髪の毛
けんすけ：無理無理無理
はじめ：フラフラするね
けんすけ：うわーーー％＃＆＄＊
はじめ：なんて？
はじめ：髪の毛だ、大丈夫だ
はじめ：あの、幽霊はな脅かしてくるから
はじめ：俺たちがデカイ声出せれば大丈夫だ
はじめ：驚かしてこない
けんすけ：なるほどね
はじめ：だからけんすけ、声を絶対に途切れさせちゃだめだ
はじめ：わかったか？
けんすけ：オッケオッケオッケ
はじめ：なんだこの音は
けんすけ：なに？
はじめ：わかんない、怖い
けんすけ：うわああああああ
はじめ：けんすけ静かに！あ、静かにじゃない
はじめ：声出してけーーー
けんすけ：すっごい
はじめ：これ動いたら階段から転げ落ちるからね
けんすけ：え、今ここでやったら多分危ないから、多分
はじめ：大丈夫だと思う
けんすけ：上がってからでしょ？すっっっご
はじめ：確かに
はじめ：待って怖い早く行こ、見たくない
けんすけ：すいませんでした
はじめ：すいませんでした、退治(？)致しました
けんすけ：ありがとうございました
けんすけ：マジでやめてよ
けんすけ：ほんとに
はじめ・けんすけ：ああああああああああああああ
はじめ：無理無理無理
けんすけ：どこ行けばいいの？
はじめ：けんすけ、心
はじめ：ちょっと汗見て
はじめ：ちょっと待って、暑い
けんすけ：ちょ、ほんとにやめよ
はじめ：こっから先はライト無しです
けんすけ：これ行かなくてもおもろくないすか？
はじめ：ここでリタイヤしたら
はじめ：アンチに叩かれるぞ
はじめ：行こう
はじめ：行くぞーけんすけ
はじめ：あーーー始まるこれ
けんすけ：マジで待って
はじめ：またいうと(？)これ動いて…けんすけ側だから大丈夫
けんすけ：待って
はじめ：待ってほんとに
はじめ：うわああああ声聞こえる
はじめ：声聞こえる、声聞こえる
けんすけ：やめて
はじめ：声！声！
けんすけ：おかしいよ
はじめ：階段は危ないから狙ってこないんだよ
けんすけ：なる
はじめ：落ちたら危ないかんね
はじめ：ここは休めるよ
けんすけ：シーー
はじめ：うーーーーーっわロッカーだけはマジでダメ
けんすけ：絶対開くやつだ
はじめ：うわあああああ無理無理無理
けんすけ：うわあああうわああああうわあああああ
はじめ：うわあああはいはいはいはいはい
けんすけ：うわあああああああああうわあああああ
けんすけ：どこどこ、どっちどっち
はじめ：前、真っ直ぐ、行こ、真っ直ぐいこ
はじめ・けんすけ：うわあああああああ
はじめ：うわ
けんすけ：うぅーうぅー
けんすけ：突っ切る？
はじめ：突っ切ろけんすけ
はじめ：大丈夫
けんすけ：行けないよマジで
はじめ：大丈夫だ
はじめ：大丈夫だけんすけ　大丈夫
けんすけ：マジで無理
はじめ：大丈夫　大丈夫
はじめ：大丈夫大丈夫
はじめ：大丈夫パンツ履いてなくてもいいよ、大丈夫
けんすけ：ほんとに〜
けんすけ：ほんとに、ほんとに無理
はじめ：うわああああああああ　落ち着け
けんすけ：わあああああああああああ
はじめ：落ち着けけんすけ、落ち着け
オバケ：ああああああああ
はじめ・けんすけ：うわああああああああ、ああああああああああ
はじめ：待ってぇ、目つぶりたいよね
はじめ：待ってこの音のさ、ドンだけやめてほしいよ、お願いします
はじめ：許してください　ドゥンドゥンじゃない！
はじめ：ビーーじゃない！
けんすけ：ううううううう
はじめ：うわあああああ
はじめ・けんすけ：うわあああああああああああああ
けんすけ：先行こ
はじめ：まだだ
けんすけ：うわぁ　　あああああああ
はじめ：うわああ　ああああああ
はじめ・けんすけ：ハァハァハァハァ
はじめ：うわぁそれ動く多分、うん動く動く
けんすけ：いやあああ
はじめ：動く
はじめ・けんすけ：うわああああああ
けんすけ：あああああああああ
はじめ・けんすけ：うわああああ　ああああああ
オバケ：う”あ”あ”あ”
はじめ：あああああ無理無理
けんすけ：うわあああああああああああ
けんすけ：お願いします
はじめ：お願いします
けんすけ：あの勝手に閉まるんだ、マジで頭おかしいぞこいつ
はじめ：ううう怖い、無理だ
はじめ：無理無理無理無理
けんすけ：終わった終わった終わった
はじめ：目開けれない開けれない開けれない
はじめ：無理無理ドンドンやめて
はじめ：無理、無理、無理、無理
けんすけ：あーあ、おかしい
はじめ：あぁ〜霊安室か
けんすけ：うわ、これ通んなきゃいけないの
はじめ：ねぇー
オバケ：う”あ”あ”あ”
はじめ：うわああああ無理無理無理
けんすけ：あああああああ
はじめ：無理無理無理無理無理
けんすけ：うわああああああああああああ
はじめ・けんすけ：あああああああああ
はじめ：うーうーうーうーうーうーうーううーーー
けんすけ：開いた、ちゃちゃっと行きましょう
はじめ：そうだなけんすけ、きも、気持ちよ
はじめ：待ってまじでまじでやばい
けんすけ：どうなってんのこれ？
はじめ：まじでやばい×３
けんすけ：どうなってんのこれ
はじめ：うーわ、無理無理顔怖い怖い怖い
けんすけ：おーおーおーおー
はじめ：ドンドンやめてください皆さんお願いします
はじめ：僕たちはダメな人たち　僕たちはダメな人です
はじめ：僕たちにドンしたら本当に
けんすけ：やめよ
はじめ・けんすけ：うわあああああ　あああああ
はじめ：うわぁいてっ　いてっ
けんすけ：いてーーー
【はじめしょちょーエンディング　ホラーver.】
はじめ：まじで怖い　見て俺の汗
はじめ：まじで怖かったぁ
はじめ：けんすけよくやった
はじめ：よくやったけんすけ、よく頑張った